all right what does it do all right
dang dude man I look like a frickin comb
my hair with a damn shovel I'm alright I
have on pants wet arm and I don't know
if this has ever happened to you but I'm
I've on pants with sandals pants with
sandals and and every time I do that I
feel my feet feel like they're just up
to no good
you know my feet feel like they're my
legs feel like they're being normal and
my feet feel like they're being naughty
just cuz I guess like the cold air kind
of hits them and you know and they're
just so damn exposed if you were in damn
you know you got your damn toes out
there you're freaking your little dangle
pieces out there at the end of your feet
because your toes are just like almost
like 10 small like little Florida's just
hanging off your body but yeah when I
have pants on it and sandals I feel oh
and then a dog comes up and licks your
toes oh I mean let's be honest right
that's the dark arts right there yeah
man
[Music]
[Applause]
that's that intro hit her right there
this signee
that's a signing sign e that's Thai nice
and who putting that sound paste on your
damn hearing when you're hearing brushes
and uh and if you guys don't know who
tiny is Tiny's uh you know he's at rare
earth element tiny sand who is a man you
know when when this pod you know when we
first started doing this he would send
us sound and he records deep in the
earth we don't know where he's from I
mean if you took a damn if you quit you
know quit combing your hair with a
shovel and use the shovel naturally in
its natural locale into the earth I bet
somewhere down there you'd find a damn
treasure box and you'd open it up and
inside of there be tiny sand who a small
man we don't know how I mean nobody's
seen him and he'd be playing a little
bitty ah a little bitty wheats ha you
know but that's him
he hit me through email years ago in
every couple months you send in
something and this message came from him
and this is all truthful and this is all
honest he said hey man I've been living
a different life in a different
dimension for a while but [ __ ] that man
I'm back and coming through with that
interplanetary hitter a cover of sweet
child of mine and that's it tiny sand
whoo and that could be Middle Eastern
I'm not sure what he is but uh but we're
gracious for that hitter and we're
hoping to have a new website up here in
the next two weeks and then people can
submit their sounds music melodies and
this and that to be a part of the
experience and uh and that'll be that
what's going on not much man um what did
I do this weekend really you know I got
my nieces and nephews are coming out
here in two weeks to go to Disney see
them
mouths you know it and I remember when I
was real young you know they had a man
next door kind of an older guy and I
don't want to say a pervert but he
always said his zipper on his pants
didn't work well so you know you can
kind of you could get a dang uh you
could get a stencil and some markers and
draw your own conclusion on that but
this man he would always say come see
the mouse you know you don't want to go
to Disney World come see the mouse and
you get by I mean hey he had a little
mouse in his hand a little bitty Mouse
you know reminds me of that circus mouse
on Green Mile member in that movie
remember that movie that killed the big
black guy that killed Michael Clarke
Duncan and they got the man on there
with the circus mouse that little white
kind of shifty guy looked like he looked
like his eyes are playing uh like in a
little bit of an arm like look like his
eyes are always kind of shooting at each
other a little bit he got that little
circus mouse you know he goes oh it's
gonna be a little bit of circus mouse
remember now but I could see myself I
don't know if I could train animals okay
actually I could you know I don't want
to doubt myself that's one thing
recently I've been tired of just
doubting myself you know I want to
believe I want to just start to just
believe that I could do what I want to
do all right do anything like a train
animals I could you know I could be a
high diver you know I could uh you know
I can hold my breath for a long time you
know it is different it could be
anything man could be really anything
and over I just I guess I want to start
believing in myself more what else was I
thinking about I went to look at a car
you know and I'm looking at a Jeep Grand
Cherokee and I always wanted to have one
and so they my treating myself and
getting something like that you know
just that hit are you out there that
little you know that little ah and you
got that vehicle and your cruise and I
love that do
remember when you were young and you
left the house for the first time in
your car I remember looking back am i
focusing me like man I can't believe
they [ __ ] letting me go they know
surefire I'm about to go get me a little
better jumps you know and it was I don't
even know what holiday was Thanksgiving
do it I'll get a couple damn turkey
johns and just just Huff them things and
just get my lungs all freaking you know
cornucopia cooked out brah I was just
literally I drove 200 feet to my
neighbor's row and drove there and got
some weed and I was I remember my mom
could even see me from where I drove
down
it wasn't I lied too I said I'm going to
get something you don't want to the
market or I'm going to get some gas and
she said you have a full tank and I said
well you know I'm gonna top it off
because it was my first time that first
experience right there but I remember
that and I drove just about 200 feet
into my neighbor's driveway and bought
weed right there in front of my mom my
mom said damn you're an idiot and she
was right she was right about that one
that time now I have evolved since then
but but she was right about that but
remember how shitty everybody's car was
when you were a kid unless you were rich
then you don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about but remember how shitty
brother one dude they had this guy in
our town that's got big Samuel and he
had a van and it wouldn't shut off so
that [ __ ] you had to constantly be
putting gas in and it wouldn't shut off
dude there was no like on/off it was
either when the gas was in it would
start up and when it was out of gas it
would stop there was no I think somebody
either stole the ignition or something
happened
I saw her had me a little sip of that
coffee hmm do coffee let's be honest
it's like damn cocaine for your lungs
brah right when you bring that cup to
your mouth it's like your lungs just
pulled over under you know off the
interstate and bought it you know bought
a swift you know bought a couple just a
wet wet brown gram of uh of joy um
what's going on dude I had this cry I
have this crazy kind of thing that's
been kind of milling around in the
background and I want to share with you
but I don't want to like jinx myself do
you ever get like that like you want to
share like some news or something but
you don't want to like jinx your own
life I get like that sometimes I was at
the comedy store this weekend everybody
was in Montreal for the Comedy Festival
and I was just by myself and and um and
I get this thing at night where like I
get you know I'd like everything was
good in the next scene oh I downloaded
snapchat and you know snapchat should be
shut down I mean anything can get
through snap it's like our borders
basically it's like whatever
here's they got a meal they got you know
snapchat is very it's just so dangerous
I know I've talked about it before but I
didn't really realize this you know I
get this thing at night when I'm by
myself and it just like I get like
Restless like I just I don't know I just
get restless I want to do something you
know but I don't even know what I want
to do sometimes I just don't know what I
want to do but it's like I want to like
growl at something or I want to I just
don't want to just I'm gonna just you
know just nibble on something a titty or
something I don't know what it is
something I just want to do something I
have this thing and not I get restless
and maybe it's just you know it could be
like a sign of the times like because
we're going from such an era of just
human human to electronics you got to
think about that I mean you know 30
years ago the only volts going through
your body was a heartbeat
that was in if you wanted to check me
for some type of rhythm or a voltage or
something heartbeat that was a you know
that systole and diastole bruh and those
were also a couple of kind of redneck
brothers in my town twins you know
systole and diastole Harper was the last
name but that's also you know that's
party our aortas because your heart just
is like a your hearts like a shoe box
but the shoes are all blood and um
anyway but if you check somebody's body
that was in the main frequency rolling
through him was that heartbeat that can
you know that couldn't mean or if they
went for a jog you know be that thinking
thinking thinking thinking or if they
was doing a little bit of coke would be
like the doctors been thinkin or if they
had just bought a shark would be like
don't don't don't don't don't
so but that was it that was your only
vibe was that your your only vibration
inside of you that your you know that
nature's drum the heart and then now you
got all that yeah there's electric waves
going everywhere you know I just wonder
sometimes if my angst is a side effect
of this all the electricity and stuff
that's in the air all the vibes that are
out that are just cruising I mean dude
there's an email if you send an email
where do you think he goes broke through
the ground dude no through the air
that's a damn word bird bro that thing
is wrong so if you're chilling if you're
chilling and next thing you know you
feel something you know I wouldn't be
surprised one day they crack a guy open
on the deathbed
and he gots a bunch of damn best buy
emails clogged up in his body or
something or some you know who knows is
what I'm tryna i guess saying about so
that's been that I guess but I yeah I
guess that night sometimes I get kind of
I don't know there's this thing inside
of me and it just wants to act out it's
almost like a just like a it feels like
a little gopher that won't brush his
teeth or something he's just hiding like
in the base of my neck and in the back
of my wiener and he wants to just be out
there and he wants to be naughty man
that's how I feel sometimes I can't I
wish I could explain it to you better
but that happens to me at night
a lot of time by myself I get that that
not ego for just milling just I mean
that thing is just [ __ ] loitering
around in the back of my nuts in my
nutsack you know it and in France they
say nuts suck and that's nuts at but
it's kind of beautiful isn't it what
else but yeah dude [ __ ] on big Sam
you'll had that van and that [ __ ]
wouldn't shut off so you had to keep it
rolling you had to just go get more gas
you would siphon gas I don't if you ever
siphon gas or ever you know giving a
[ __ ] to our arm mechanic but you get
that hard hit and then the gas is coming
up fast you got to get away from the
hose and if you don't get away from the
hose real quick then you can't uh then
that gas will get you you get bit by
that gas it'll jump out of the hose and
bite you in the face and you can't have
a cigarette for about a month after that
because you'll cook yourself out Oh what
else happen oh I went to a church this
weekend actually went to a church
service it was real cool in downtown in
Los Angeles I hadn't been to something
like this it was like a big event and it
was you know and I'm not you know
sending any you know the thing that I
love about an environment that I loved
about this environment was just seeing
people all types of people
being a fearless kind of fearless to
like believe in something other than
themselves
you know and now I don't even know if it
was denominational I don't think this I
don't even know if this if it had a
denominational I was called vous vo US
Conference and I it was downtown in Los
Angeles and um and it just was you know
cuz sometimes when I think about you
know when I think about like religion
and stuff and I think about faith and
and I used to not believe in anything
you know when I was young I didn't
believe in anything you not only
believed in myself early and as I get
older you know I want there and I don't
know if it says I get older as I get
more willing you know I want there to be
something else I want there to be you
know you ever go to Walmart and you
think it's just gonna go on forever
remember that you go to Walmart and
first you upfront they got the candy and
they got a couple pound cakes or
something that you know they they didn't
make quite a pound they're like
three-quarter pounds instead of
defective they got those defective thing
areas up front forty cents for a pound
cake and you got that bad [ __ ] you know
you pick a couple up at him sweet sugary
freaking breads you know it and then you
go and they got children's clothes and
then they got you know stuffed dinosaurs
and board games and then they got lotion
and then the food starts up and they got
damn watermelons and they got the aw
what are the things you know you sit
down in them and you're not sure
yourself and you can almost get trapped
kind of but but you're in Hawaii or
something not mannequins hammocks so you
got you know you got you have these you
know you keep cruising then you got TV
dinners then they got you know liquor
they got vodka and gin and everything
then they got 700 you know different
types of orange juice and you think
Walmart's never gonna end man
you just keep going and going you
running through that thing and you just
they got milk and then they got live
animals and they got guns
then they got Genesis then they got
Exodus and then they got um you know
next thing you know you're in a
Terminator 3 like there's just so many
different sections of Walmart but then
you get to the back of it you get to the
wall it's like ah man this it ends you
know you notice some tall it's back
there and there's like a there's like a
thing that there's like literally like
600 signs that tell employees to wash
their hands which is bizarre I think
like gee like what kind of problems are
we having you know if people aren't
washing their hands that much you know
especially if they're handling
everything everything from board games
to bison jerky to uh you know adult
suppositories and and uh what was I
talking about
oh this was it and I think that's what I
think about life you know I don't want
there to be or not life existence you
know I don't want there to be nothing
else I just don't want there to be you
know I think it would be real scary to
let go of like the life of the existence
that we know but you know I think that
you know that God is like an Oregon he
does origami and we're the paper and
he'll just fold us and put us out into
something and you know here he fought
you got folded up into a human and then
next time we put you hip make it down MA
a little raccoon out there or something
and you're in France or you're in Japan
maybe he'll make you you know he'll fold
you up and you were uh you were just a
like a pack of starbursts or something
out there you know anything you could be
a fireball maybe a you you know you work
for a dragon you're a fireball but it's
like I want to be folded up into
something else when I'm when this is
done I just
and it was just interesting it was great
to see people just together all
different types of people man I mean
they had they had this one little guy in
this little ah you know he was like kind
of like Asian and Mexican this little
kind of V Aten and you know Viet and the
next this Viet next second this little
Viet next sick and this do was you know
he had these peace Tola he had his hands
like he stole us and he was just just
kind of almost working this little guy
and he might have had a back problem and
if you have a back problem then
everything we do is kind of working a
little bit and you know that and in
anyway he uh but I was watching him just
sing these songs and they had everybody
just fired up and did I got so much joy
out of just watching somebody else have
fun so it was it was a anyway it was
just it was a neat experience it was
just a neat experience to see people not
being afraid to admit that they want to
believe in something other than
themselves because that's where I have a
tough time with a lot of things in my
life I'm finding recently I just want to
do things myself and I you know I want
to believe in things myself you know I
just it's hard to let go it's hard to
just really let go but man it looked
when people do it and they it looked fun
man it look joyous to see people just
really just surfing on that beautiful
five five just being free man they just
people seem free but yeah if you get to
the imagine when you get to the back of
the Walmart when you hit the wall it all
kind of just by the yogurts bra you know
they'll have about forty yards of yogurt
off a tear often and uh in like a big
kind of you know milk kennel and they
got a mean and they got peach yogurt and
the damn uh I mean he got so many types
of yogurt man when are we shutting this
[ __ ] down then we need to build a wall
around some of these cows udders because
the types I mean they got I mean every
type of
Gertz coming in man you got a lot did I
do that that's all I'm
yogurts bruh dude you can't have lime
and dairy what what kind of cow is it's
like the Stevo of cows you can't have
that lime and area'd that they are their
arch-rivals and they have that they had
the other day they had our Spanish
yogurt what the [ __ ] is that dude that's
just yogurt so it just seemed like
there's a lot going on out there and
when you get to the back of the Walmart
but when you hit that wall it just I
remember as a kid I thought it went on
forever I thought I'd be able to keep
just running past the frozen foods past
a big huge thing of the beach balls you
know maybe get to England who knows next
thing you know I'm underwater next II
know I'm dating Arielle next thing you
know I got 101 Dalmatians and Cruella's
[ __ ] dead bro and I'm living life
letting them puppies run over my my body
just letting them pup-pups just just pop
her in all of her daddy's [ __ ] naked
back so I don't know man I just I don't
know do I
you know what I dunno actually I don't
want there to be nothing and I don't
think there is I think life is too much
of an experience for there not to be
more man you know more will be revealed
that's what I want and I believe that
you get what you believe what you want I
believe you get that if you want to be a
salamander when you when you die you
next thing you know you're gonna be
swimming for a long time people don't
think about that
some people like oh I want to be uh a
fish when I die well dude have you I
swam for nine minutes dude and my cousin
birthday party almost do around
almost drowned imagine swimming [ __ ]
24 hours a day and fish can't even sleep
brilli
a fish because if they only sleep on on
the banks you know they can only sleep
on the bank and if they jump on the bank
that can only sleep for five or six
seconds or eight seconds before they get
real nervous because there's no because
it's air and then you [ __ ] swimming
again that looks hectic what else I had
some sushi this weekend I don't know if
you guys have ever gotten involved with
this damn I mean it's really the dark
arts what they're doing to these fish
man the Japanese man it's uh
I mean basically it's really Sushi's
pretty much about the it's about the
freshest Chinese food you have ever had
so I mean I'd rather pay him you know I
love Chinese food you know dude you give
me an orange chicken a little bit of
cinnamon on that you give me that
freaking that all that Sargent pepper
chicken or whatever it is a little bit
of arms chicken throw a little bit of
cinnamon on that brah
sprinkle that seni on that [ __ ] on
them vittles baby come out
mm you know finish that hitter off maybe
polish it all off with a low menthol
cigarettes that Lord's meal but yeah
means sushi it's basically look I'd
rather I'd pay him two extra dollars
cook the [ __ ] you know and they're not
here's the deal for me they're not even
I've never heard of any of the fish they
gave a box this sushi box about $50 $50
for the box you think it's a board game
and you open it up and stamp fish you
know it's like whoa where the hell's
balderdash
y-you know it just can very confusing
and the fish you never heard of him
tamarind Oh what is that where is that
I've never heard of that you know why
because nobody has and then they got you
know they got the they got salmon in
there they got the Maki Maki dude I want
that hard polish I want the where's the
where's the good [ __ ] baby where the
bass we're at least throw a couple cuts
of [ __ ] fresh bass and this bastard
you know at least carved me a little
carp
you feel me carp a carp daddy it's like
put something in here that I that I can
deal with or just cook it cuz sushi man
it's just I don't hate it but I don't
get it you know and I don't know a lot
of people that do it's good but what is
it though and why aren't why aren't they
cooking it look into it that's all I'm
saying oh I don't even know I'm talking
about today dude what am I talking about
no no no I got my hopes up I got my
hopes up
and and we'll see you know I uh who
knows
life is so wild
dude how about Tanya Milosevic to behead
in unbelievable wouldn't and if you
haven't listened to that episode she's
young blind lady that came in and just
man I you know I've been having trouble
I was thinking about not doing
interviews anymore because I did the
jordan belfort when and I don't I didn't
like him honestly I didn't like him and
I hate to say that but I didn't I didn't
like him and I didn't but I didn't do a
good job of trying to figure out what
was going on with him or figure out like
what made him you know seem greedy or
behave a certain way or or just I don't
know I feel like I probably could have
tried to do a better job of connecting
with him and so I don't know we're gonna
try and just look at a different way
that we can do interviews and who we
interview to make it more of an
experience that I can be comfortable in
and enjoy and want to engage in you know
I wish I would have asked him you know
we're talked about greed and what I
think about greed and where I find greed
in my life and how I could have related
it to him or I don't know I just felt
like and I'm not being hard on myself I
just want to do it well I don't want
like wasting people's time you know if
you think about time then you can't even
think about it forever because you'll
run out of it so it's you know it's that
tricky ticky
it's that tricky tick tick ticky but I
thought the I thought interview talking
with her was so cool man it really just
you know it just made me it made me want
to learn more you know it made me want
to believe that that I can be that I can
learn more and then I can you know just
it may you believe that there's I don't
know it just made me think oh wow there
is a
way that I can do this and enjoy it
there's more out there you know there's
a there's a Walmart that goes on forever
man I'm talking I'm never ending will
Hall Mart here and I know that's what
Nixon had called the episode as well
Nick picks out the episode titles if you
don't know that
just the filling in on that oh I do have
some really cool news so we're gonna do
single moms a night out in San Francisco
if you know a single mother who you'd
like to nominate you can hit the hotline
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three you know don't you know just
be care be careful about it we don't
want to hurt anybody's feelings or
anything like that so but yeah we would
love to to do take treat a single mother
out to the show one night and then do
something nice for them in there kiddo
or kiddos but we are it looks like any
way we're gonna be able to start an
actual nonprofit or that's the goal so
gonna be having someone work full-time
not full-time part-time so sometimes on
building that you know helping out
single mothers or helping out single
mothers who are you know financially
unstable financially troubled and that
that all of our single moms having been
on some of these ladies assaults of
different types but in order for it to
be an actual nonprofit you have to it
has to be charitable that's one thing I
learned so we have to make sure that we
will help out people that are really
struggling and so anyway we're gonna
we're gonna be able to look we're gonna
work on that reven somebody look into
that and really kind of move that
forward and apply for a non-profit or
ship so pretty cool pretty cool you know
I have in visions of like a you know
having like um places like where these
where moms can live and just take a
little bit of stress off of their lives
so that they can you know just create
more of a hopefully a create more of
like an emotional
well world for them in there in there
kiddos man that cool wouldn't be cool so
thank you so much to everybody that
supports this podcast because it's slow
it just takes things take a long time
you know it's like the government kind
of things just take a while but we are
doing it we can do this and and I'm just
starting to try and believe that in my
life that that if we want to change the
world or do something different than we
really can that sounds crazy to say that
sometimes but I was laying in bed a
couple of weeks ago and I just had that
thought was like man we could change the
world you know because what I'd rather
believe that then that we couldn't you
know then that we stuck out here you
know that that you know that it's all
just superglue and then I'm not super
then I'm stuck so I think we could do I
mean it's crazy maybe I sound like a
crazy person but you know what you have
to you got a book you know somebody's
crazy before they're crafty you know
somebody runs up on you in the park and
is like hey brah
you know I'll blow you right now and
you're like no way buddy and then next
thing you know you know so first they
sound crazy but then it could be crafty
you know do what you got to do today's
episode I don't know I'm talking about
saying do my neck starts hurting like 25
minutes into these episodes I got to get
a a new neck so thank you to everybody
that came out in Los Angeles two weeks
ago I want to thank you so much that
came out at The Improv it was fun man
the first show it was so much fun I mean
it was just a real real hoot and that
was a joy and I just want to thank you
and everybody that came out to King in
the sting last week with me and Brendan
Schaub we did a live show and it wasn't
live it was just me and it was just
stand-up comedy but we're gonna be
working on a live show and I'll see you
in San Francisco this weekend so you can
know that
at Cobbs comedy club Thursday Friday and
Saturday support for this past weekend
comes from manscaped and de manscaped as
a company and they're number one in
men's below the belt grooming so if you
look down by your junk and you ain't
seeing joy you should change it because
you you junk should be really just you
want that hitter down there you want
that hair you know you want that kind of
hairless hitter manscaped offers
precision-engineered tools for your
family jewels I didn't write that but I
read it
now I've groomed myself before and I've
knit my I hate to say this man cuz it's
you know but I'm you know I've nipped
you know I've knit my little game hen
before with our scissor and I have man
not a big nip but just enough and man a
thing it uh it's got a lot of blood in
it I'll say that you know and that's
kind of edgy and I'm sorry I shouldn't
be talking like that but but manscaped
is forever changing the grooming game
with their perfect package 2.0 inside
the perfect package you'll find the
electric trimmer called the lawn mower
2.0 it's waterproof skin safe technology
keep you from Nick and that sack and the
only person that is allowed to Nick and
sack at the same time is Kris Kringle
baby jolly old Santa Claus Saint Nick
with that sack of gifts you can create
less mess by trimming in the shower with
that uh with that electric trimmer the
lawn mower the waterproof one you can
get those hard-to-reach places they got
a little tool called the plow and you
can share crop your own freakin uh your
own body I mean you definitely you got
forty acres and you got that mule baby
that a little long you got that
instrument that they give you let's not
forget about that crop preserver it's an
anti chafing ball deodorant wow they go
in deep and
moisturise are who now back off the
moisturizers are a little man you'll end
up doing other things to yourself end up
touching yourself to full pleasure and
blasting why are you not putting
deuteron on the smelliest part of your
body that's what they're wondering it's
time to get clean with the perfect
package 2.0 get 20% off free shipping
with the code theo at manscape calm
always use the right tools get 20% off
and free shipping with the code Theo
th EO @ manscaped comm 20% off with Free
Shipping at manscape com use code you
know Theo so that's our only ad today
and that cool man and that cool when
it's nice and there's not a lot of ads
let's get into some calls and great
calls came in you know I've been
struggling recently to kind of like feel
a lot of my own feelings and I just want
to share that some you know I'd like to
come on here sometimes and talk about
what I'm feeling and stuff but honestly
I've just been so but things have been
so busy recently it's been hard to have
a lot of feelings you know because you
need more space for those and and I'm
gonna try to get some more of that going
in my life you know just go to more
meetings it's a more 12-step and go to
um and what else go to uh and maybe do
some meditation somebody looking into
that man give my chakras you know give
them a little bit of a rest we got some
calls that came in as always the hotline
is nine eight five six six four nine
five zero three and and I do want to say
thank you don't know if I say it enough
want to say thank you so much for just
being a part of this if we're paying
attention sometimes and for coming out
on the road you know I really I get to
live my dreams right now and it's crazy
you know I get to live my dreams and
sometimes I'm still agitated you know
but that's just me that's just who I am
I'm not going to change sometimes and
you know and it's different like it's
just I don't know man
you know it's hard like you know I don't
sometimes feel like I know I've done
enough work and stuff in my life and in
stand-up comedy to be able to have the
ability to entertain people when they
come out to the show I know that I've
done enough of my homework so that I can
apply it now on a regular basis but
still I feel I think there's always a
part of us that feels not deserving and
some people say we know man you deserve
it this and that's and I appreciate that
but I want there to always be a part of
me that feels a little less deserving um
because I need that part of me you know
I need that part of me to keep me I
think I need that part of me anyway they
just kind of I don't know it's just like
a thermostat it's like I know the
setting and sometimes the setting
doesn't leave me feeling great but it's
still the setting that I know the best
and it's a setting that I can operate at
but I just I'm so grateful man thank you
guys so much for I mean I get I I mean I
just can't even tell you it's like I
always kind of believe I always believed
in myself I think but I never you never
really you you know you just don't know
you know you don't know you just don't
know what's gonna happen and and I'm not
saying like I haven't I'm not walking on
the moon or I'm not know Danny DeVito or
anything like that or you know Ronald
Palmer or anything but I mean I'm having
like an opportunity to live out some of
my dreams man and I'll tell you this man
it's awesome you know it's really really
cool it's really cool when somebody
comes up that's that's just like me from
where I'm from or that's different than
me says hey man I you know I you make me
laugh or my wife and I had fun or you
know I can relate to you and like it's
wild I don't feel like out of
her dad and nobody kind of does but I'm
happy I do want to be do my best to be
able to be a part of you know like I
don't know man I just you know I want to
feel like I I mean I do feel like I
don't know I'm just thankful man I'm
just grateful and so thank you very much
and and and and I'm excited about being
able to just be a part of whatever's
going on in the world and hopefully
bring you know bring some joy out there
let's get to a couple calls man here we
go hey whoa this is drew from just south
of Portland Oregon I just finished the
podcast with Tanya you're amazing blind
lady that you found and I just thought
that you should definitely tell her that
she needs to start a podcast because she
just filled that every question that you
had without a hiccup you know she just
she took it all right on the chin and I
just really appreciated her ability to
not flinch and just you know roll with
the punches and answer the questions and
I think it'd be a really interesting
perspective hearing her gang getting
much love appreciate that man yeah like
I said mentioned earlier man it was
incredible you know she made me feel
like I wasn't doing anything with even
all the capabilities that I you know
with you know the get the gifts that I
have inside of me she made me really
feel like that and yeah man she just
really is this uh isn't it interesting
that she said I feel like she's such a
gift to the world and she can't even see
the world nice wasn't that wild man and
I hope her next life if she wants to she
gets to see it all man and then imagine
when she realizes what a gift she was
and how she handled herself like I mean
she's the dang she's basically the
princess Charles of the blind I feel
like or of a narrative any impairment
and it's so inspiring and you know what
I'm gonna send that call at this
voicemail to her so she gets it man
you're right
you know you're really really right and
I hope I hope I'm there after in the app
you know and whatever's after this man I
hope you know we're at the you know we
get to go to the endless well you know
there's a behind the wall you know
behind the Walmart or whatever you know
that that never-ending Walmart and hope
there's an aisle where it's just you see
like people that can't that have an
impairment and they get it they get
given the gift you know man you imagine
that Jesus sorry could you imagine an
aisle like you you know you close your
eyes for the last time and then your
spirit just takes off in like a
never-ending Walmart in and every aisle
has something special in it you know and
in one aisle there's like you know you
see a blind person who gets a gift of
sight man and they can see and then you
know God shows them or some higher power
shows them or the spirit the entity you
know that puffed of you know Puff the
Magic Dragon whoever it is do sheera
whoever it is mine you know chief
Gillespie whoever it is shows them what
a good job they did or or at least sits
down or even for you know they got
another row as people that was murderers
or people that was on not flushing the
toilet and people you know people that's
being dirty and they got it you know God
sitting there whoever you know coyote
John or whatever that guy's name is um
not Punxsutawney Phil who is it
Yogi Bear whoever's running the the
Walmart to sit there they've got the
hand on their shoulder and they they
show him why you know X's and O's on a
piece of paper why they shouldn't do
murdering and that guy's like oh I see
now you know I just hope there's I hope
there's just I hope the aisles keep
going because I want to I just I believe
they can and I think if we if enough of
us believe that that something else
could be there's something bigger out
there than us
maybe everybody else has been and I'm
the one who's missing some of the boats
sometimes by trying to think too much to
myself and want to control it all myself
[Music]
you know and some people don't like
thinking about religion or talking
religion I don't know if I'm really
talking about that but I also don't want
to be afraid of what I don't want to be
afraid to think or talk about stuff on
here you know I don't have to be right
I'm not here to be right to you
hell I'm not even here to be right to me
so you know I'm talking about Jesus dude
why don't we keep doing this every week
let's take another call man right here
gang gang thanks for the call - and
thank you for that sweet message - time
yeah what a gift that we got huh well
she was so eloquent and how she man she
made me think like if blind people seem
like they're not interested we're sorry
we sometimes just don't I mean she she
could see her part in everything that
was going on in the world and man it was
incredible it was really really
incredible dude I listen back to it
yesterday
and his the first time I ever done that
you know it was really really incredible
here we go
big Billy Boy out there in Dubuque and I
do Dubuque azam it's beautiful over
there man
if you like Iowa and you like the Butte
then you really then you're right then
you're gonna love it
gang bruh that [ __ ] mapa dactyl son
right there in the middle of the map and
a lot of people want to you know say
this and that about the Midwest about
certain areas how about that Louisiana
Purchase Papa tat LP buying okay we
bought a third of America for what
$80 brah greatest deal ever son Shing
Shing boy Shing Shing boy at Ricky Davis
daddy gang homework getting off work I
work for FedEx delivering of residential
packages you feel me oh I feel you you
freaking resi Arnez baby
and your gift is home yeah you hitting
them Residential's dude I'd be [ __ ]
peeing in people's side yards daddy I'll
be laid off the first day I'd be laid
off man
and you also borrow big Samuels van dude
on you got to keep unlimited gas in it
dude we used to have to tape these big
tanks on the side of it of just gas so
it would just be unlimited gas cuz it
you couldn't turn it off man and you
couldn't turn it on once the gas went in
and went on let's hear more man thank
you for your service baby on the way to
work
[ __ ] I listened to it the whole time
I'll deliver it man that's what I'm
saying boy from you and Brendan Schwab I
appreciate you guys alright keep on
keepin on Gang Gang
buzz buzz brother gang gang man buzz
buzz yeah Brendan's a nice guy man you
know he's got a big card and you know I
just read this weekend man I was just
feeling so lucky to be in some of that
circle you know I wasn't feeling good
about something and I needed summit
suggestions some advice and I called
Brian Cowen and he you know he's just so
helpful you know and for him to just be
so helpful to me and like you know I
know we're you know we work in the same
business but I'm just so uh and maybe we
all we all are we all are fortunate to
have somebody you know and and if you
don't have somebody man I'm sorry man
but I think you just be patient you know
some somebody will you know there's
somebody out there looking for you to be
your friend I believe that you know and
sometimes we don't even notice the
people that we have you know sometimes
we just really need to notice and
sometimes I don't even want to notice
the people that care about me because I
don't want to you know I'd rather just
say in stance it's easier for me to sit
there and say nobody cares nobody cares
you know it's just easier to do that
sometimes man it's harder
it's harder sometimes to just stand up
and say yeah you know here the people
that do care about me and I and if I go
and I'm gonna thank them you know I
don't know I'm not trying to tell you
what to do I'm just I don't know man
I've been having like a lot of weird
feelings I've been I've been adjusting
my medication a little bit but you know
not in a bad way I'm safe and all but I
would like to one day get off of these
antidepressants so I'm not doing it but
I cut my the amount I take down some
because I would like to one day not take
them you know I'm reading this really
interesting book that's uh that really
talks about that and I'm hoping to have
the author in one day let's take another
call who's listening 8bo this is Eric
over here in Utah studying for the Texas
bar exam just finished law school just
pass car oh yeah you finished law school
huh then torts bro you've been eating
them lemming torts baby I feel you
congratulations man studying for that
bar study for that Roseanne Barr bro
grab your crotch and sing the national
anthem dude gang
Bassam Esther and I'm actually watching
you that's 214 now you were saying
something about you know wanting to know
who listens and I gotta tell you man
I've been in you know like I said in law
school for the past three years with
these crazy-ass rich kids I'm a factory
workers kid my parents are fresh off the
boat gang bruh you like Rudy Ruettiger
dude that's what you are people yelling
Rudy Rudy you could like quiet down we
got a cross-examination going on you're
gonna be the only one in the courtroom
wearing a jersey dude and a cast on your
arm and getting everybody fired up
the judge is him like approach the bench
please you can't wear a gold helmet in
here sir gang man I bet your parents are
so proud of you man you know what's
amazing man that's the earth that's
unique is that the struggle or whatever
that is that's the magic dude if you
don't have a so funny I was talking to
Dustin Poirier the other day and he made
me think dude it's so funny Dustin
Poirier
obviously everybody knows I'm a huge fan
and he's a UFC fighter and uh and we're
both from Louisiana but you know he for
a guy sometimes he's so in suffering for
a fighter he's oddly so insightful and I
guess maybe I shouldn't say that cuz I
kind of like puts down fighters but
here's the thing people think there's a
general thought out there that athletes
sometimes aren't that insightful well
that's not true and I'm probably the one
who [ __ ] takes it so really this is
me that have it that had that talk but
he was saying that if you're an underdog
man the beauty of being a someone who
has to go through struggle the beauty
because you get that there's no if
there's no struggle there's no that's
the thing oh then it's nothing there's
no journey
there's no journey you know you get to
make that Magic Man you get to be the
story like once you get to a place of
like uh you know of an insane comfort
unless you're your kids then they get to
they have to make a different story like
if you say you're able to you come from
you know from lower means and you get to
higher means in your life then your kids
maybe they they give away all the wealth
that you that you accumulated you know I
don't know it's like and not that it
gets taken from them by a government
everything I'm saying they get to give
like it's just it's like what is our
journey what is the thing what is the
because that's what it that's I don't
know man
it's like all the things in my life that
I thought like you made me like not have
any value or made me like feel like
nothing or like all my struggle is
that's my path and that's like I now I
can show people this is my you know that
was Lewis and Clark man you know I
wasn't freaking uh you know bear Brian
or whatever you know it's like I don't
know
it's like if you have if you have a
distance to go then you have you have
then
you get to have a journey imagine being
born into an environment you never even
get to have a journey and everybody we
all have when we have to figure out what
it is you know and I do believe that as
well we all have one we all have a way
that we can not only inspire ourselves
others that we could change the world
man we could I don't know I'm feeling
hopeful but also [ __ ] I think my dad
I'm we're just kind of getting tight on
my head but but congratulations ma'am or
you know I don't ride with any of them
and then to you know listen to show men
here's some real down-to-earth should
really just brings me back and it's
really been super helpful for me men so
you know just keep it going brother
gang gang dude and when I go to jail for
something you can come and support me
brah like your attitude that's cool man
a slow clap with Charles s Dutton
remember him standing on the sidelines
of Rudy dude if you don't watch Rudy at
Christmas dude or after sex then who are
you
that's what I want to know if you don't
watch Rudy Ruettiger
to help you get an erection I mean know
if the movie Rudy if that nothing helps
you get an erection Warren I'm watching
that and that's a freebie right there
let's take another call here man big
will for Martha's Vineyard ah dang and I
heard Martha's vineyard's been shaved
you feel me uh-uh
that's old uh when the moat cooter jokes
homework I'm 22 and I still pretty lost
in life man I got my 19 year old
girlfriend pregnant and we met on July
4th 2018 the baby's due August 17 2019
about a month from now feeling pretty
down because sometimes I feel like she
might be better off about she was she
had so much potential you know like
she's going to a really good
school was gonna get into pre-med all
all kind of got thrown away cuz I got a
pregnant but well I'm innocent erupted
you'll quit me at first of all thanks
for calling in man you know I cannot
even fathom that it's so wild when
you're young you go from like man I
gotta get laid I gotta get laid and then
once you get lady get somebody pregnant
you're like [ __ ] that's crazy I didn't
that wasn't part of the goal and look at
you you some of these things you I'm
already saying you can't put all these
weights on yourself man she maybe she
could be better off without you maybe
you're not ready maybe it's not the best
fit that could be true maybe you could
be better off you know without her it's
like the some of that could be true man
but I don't want you you know I can't
relate to this story exactly because I
haven't had this experience but I don't
want you to be you know don't put all it
sound like you already have like a lot
you're putting a lot of pressure on
yourself and you don't know if she was
gonna go to pre-med she still may go to
pre-med she may be one of the best baby
doctors in the world in ten years you
know this may be a gift that you're not
able to see yet how this is how this
toys gonna you know not this toy but
this you know this human this baby is
gonna play out in your life you don't
you don't know it unless you're more
smiling happy sometimes I feel like I
can't be the man I seen I make enough
money to support her and the newborn and
I struggle and I struggle a lot with my
fears of becoming just like my daddy
wasn't around that's feeling of
self-doubt you know basically what I'm
trying to say feel now I understand my
own father's choice to not be there and
I want to break the cycle man nothing
but for my girl and my daughter well
sweetie to call him and and it's also
sweetie you to write this down before
you called you know cuz sometimes you
have to and I you know like up
refer people to call and just share but
I know it's hard sometimes I just don't
like it to not be like real you know
sometimes I worry that people are just
making fake calls and stuff but I don't
worry about that too much
oh I could have been a young dad man I'm
so I can't even imagine it's so scary
you know it's so scary but the cool one
thing that's neat is this may be an
opportunity for you to reach out to your
own father and say hey look this is
what's going on in my life and what are
some things that you would have done
different you know because I mean it's
like you'reyou're sound like your own
father left or you know separated
himself from the street from you I mean
your mom if that's the if that's the
case the man uh wow you could really I
bake a really Bert make a bridge there
what an opportunity he would have to to
find some fulfillment to and maybe he
can't help you be a father but he could
at least say look these are the things
that I did that I wish I hadn't done I
mean what inspiration you could get from
that maybe I mean it'll be very brave
you to call him and do that I don't know
which I was relationship is like so I'm
not saying that that could be really
brave and look don't just I just want
you to stack all those eggs on your on
the back Ian neck right now
you know she's the woman and the baby
and the possible relationships and her
future and those are all of that isn't
what you have to you know if to all
that's not happening right now the whole
world isn't happening right now
what's happening right now is you can
have a child August 17th or you know
whatever date you said and and you just
have you need to be a loving day you
know you you are gonna have to be active
probably you gonna have to get active
you know I believe that life is for the
active and that if you stay active maybe
you can get you you can you'll get
wherever you want to go because
one way to get from here to there
activity or magic and we don't know if
magic you know magic is part time you
know people don't know if it's you know
it doesn't work most of the time so you
got to get active papa and you can do it
do you can do it and and I think this is
a great spot we can put out some calls
out to other listeners and who want to
call and offer suggestions who have that
experience but look man I know that
there's a lot of love in the world and
if you just choose to be loving dude if
you really just choose to be loving that
you'll find the power to do it and when
there are moments you think you can't do
it you can't go to work you don't want
to apply for a job you don't want to ask
for help you don't want to to do it to
then do whatever that action is that you
don't want to do and it's so powerful
that's so powerful that contrary action
brother there's so much power in that
man
and then walls will open up you can't
even see Possible's inside of yourself
possibilities will open up you can't
even see because nothing's gonna gonna
change if you don't change the things
aren't going to be different nothing
changes if nothing changes but you know
for you to start saying hey I believe
that I could do this I believe that but
you have the chance to change a child's
life you can you can you you have a
chance to help shape that child's world
you have a chance to if you accept that
challenge man you could really you could
be that hit or daddy
and when those moments huh I think I
should just be out of her life not you
can you can be out of her life sexually
could be out of her life as a lover and
that sort of thing but but you know but
you can't be out of that child's life
dude you know I don't think you should
be I mean in the beginning you probably
could if you wanted to because the
kidding and to know anything until it's
probably two or something but you don't
want to miss all of that uh-huh you
don't want to miss smelling that little
baby's fat arm raw sucking
that [ __ ] you ever suck on a [ __ ]
baby's bicep dude the two months old
chubby ass bicep bruh yeah if that ain't
the [ __ ] if that ain't the Lord's
gristle bruh if that ain't the Lord's
gristle and a little baby they smell
like they fresh out of a you know out of
the dang oven they good after you wash
them off I'm talking about you know
after they put a little bit out of and
powder on them not really you know but I
believe you could do it man I believe if
you if you change that thought if you
change and you say I can do it you say
I'm gonna do it it's gonna hurt it's
gonna be hard cuz you know you might not
even believe it
but if you don't change your perception
nothing ever changes around us you know
I sit want my life to change but I keep
doing the same thing I go home at night
and I jerk off and do a couple
Parliament's on the on the patio then
every day and I expect in the morning
not to wake up and be tired and smell
like Parliament's on my hand
impossible I got to change things and
when I do man the water it gets bigger
man awake things get bigger that Walmart
gets a little more endless breath a few
extra aisles do now you could buy a
washer/dryer they got frigidaires over
there they got them chicken nuggets
sacks over there them 70 peace dog they
got it all they got lawn chairs they got
bougainvillea they got you know machetes
it's just you could change it man
we can change it run if you have some
suggestions for that young man though
you know he got a girl pregnant he loves
her but you heard it and he doesn't know
but I believe you could do it man
I believe we all can I really really
believe we all can and we just need each
other because you know we can't do it
alone you know neither can that baby so
I got you bro
and gang man you can hit the hotline
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three and uh and man we're lucky
you know we're lucky to be here and
we're lucky that we have each other and
and sorry if I'm assigned and preach
hear anything man I'm not trying to I
just you know sometimes I don't know
what's going on in my life and I have to
and and I have to just try my best you
know I come in here I don't have a plan
I got the calls right here the sheet
says calls we had a couple to questions
from patreon or Jacob Wells and cigar J
that I didn't get to and I'll do them
next week and and so I don't know long
doing sometimes but you know we making
it run go writing a bishop gun here
making it
[Music]
I've seen home in about a hundred days I
can almost hear mama breathe for my
restless soul and I ain't made a dollar
night spell but where it's going ain't
you me and I still get when I'm bound go
[Music]
and congratulations to Bishop Gunn guys
listen to this they will be opening up
for the Rolling Stones in Houston
Saturday July 27th at NRG Stadium Energy
stadium in that amazing man did we know
that one went when when we pick when we
don't know what's gonna happen you think
they knew that when nobody knew that
[Music]
but how I made
making good time
[Music]
I want to thank Nick and Gianni for
making uh making my life easier and
always being a part of this show
[Music]
but I'm in a good stream for the shave
Danny's brother
[Applause]
[Music]
I hate seen old men palpable to date I
can almost hear mama pray for my recipes
unless Walmart baby we can change the
world man be good to yourselves man you
deserve it and I'm gonna try to do the
same to myself you know and thank you
for always reminding me